the body of former glee star nyah rivera
has finally been recovered
her family they're here on site they've
been notified
[Music]
today naya's family got closure just
hours into day six of the search
her body was found
this weekend nya's distraught mother
yolanda
was with investigators on the lake nya's
brother michael walked arm-in-arm with
her grief-stricken father george
until george ran off jumping into the
lake to join in the search
nyah's ex ryan dorsey was clearly
emotional sitting on the shore
before he also took to the waters with
nya's family
from everything we've learned so far it
appears to be a very tragic accident
if i die young this afternoon
nya's glee family held hands by the lake
we are sadly reminded that
exactly seven years ago today cory
monteith passed away due to a heroin
and alcohol overdose jane lynch tweeted
rest sweet nyah
what a force you were love and peace to
your family you know i'm a mom now
and i you know what i love more than
acting is being josie's mom
her family will now care for nya's pride
and joy four-year-old son
josie what's the greatest thing about
being a mom everything i mean absolutely
everything you know
it's very early mornings but i am so
excited
every morning and he always greets me
with a smile and it's just so amazing to
see
so i want to be here for him and i don't
want to miss anything
[Music]
such a sad sad story and now everyone
needs to focus their thoughts and
prayers
on her family and especially her little
[Music]
boy